oh yeah what more do you want from me
you know I reviewed this fucking video
game for the DVD now you want me to do a
commentary for it get our asses alright
this is Doug Walker if you haven't
guessed yet and just gonna do a little
commentary for this and I like this
opening actually the more thing about it
no nostalgia critic on this DVD as the
traditional and establish a critic
opening of just me at my desk saying
along the nostalgia critic just
coincidence I think just for whatever
reason I thought maybe find open up this
way especially cuz I haven't done that
name video game reviews actually this is
only the second one and the reason for
that honestly is that they are harder
and they take more time and I just I
wouldn't be able to have it you know in
a week the the first one I sorted really
fast I mean I really hold ass on that
one because I didn't know what James was
gonna put out his video his movie review
and once he did I'm like okay I gotta
work fast to do this so and I already
played the game before the baby's kids
so I just went as fast as I could to get
the material and and write it out and
everything and so that was actually
pretty fed that was a couple days but it
that's all I did I didn't do any bum
reviews or anything else I only focus on
that and this of course when I doing
this now is your critic I got do other
videos as well I have to have at least
three videos a week so so yeah this is
much harder because you have to create
the footage it's not like a movie where
you just you have it and you play within
you can slow it down speed it up no you
have to create this footage you have to
show people what you're talking about
and the fight thing about is that this
is much shorter than my other reviews
and I was trying to figure out why I was
saying well it's looking at the script
is about the same length as any other
review and I realize when you're showing
what's going on it's it's very quick in
the game you don't have to wait for a
dialogue you don't have to wait for a
scene to play out and establish it in a
game it's just you either
you know something either happens or it
doesn't you either die or something you
know really annoying happens and you
just explained it so this turned out a
lot shorter I apologize
for that I mean like I say it's usually
written the same amount but I think this
is something like 1213 minutes so um but
I did do an hour game review which is
good and this game it is a bad game
don't get me wrong I don't know if it's
as bad as I built it up because at times
it can be a little fun you know just
serve a basic jump around Mario Brothers
thing but what made this really
frustrating is that in order to get the
the footage on the computer you know
again you can't do it like a movie you
have to have you have to be able to see
what you're doing so I use pinnacle
studio to import my footage and the VCR
DVD player I got only has one output so
I can only watch it on the computer on
this tiny little screen because of
course you know a wonderful Pinnacle
doesn't allow you to get the screen
bigger so I'm playing this on a very
very tiny screen so I can see it and
actually what I had to do I had to
change the resolution on the computer
screen so it could be a little larger
but not by much and it is this is a hard
game to play on a small screen you need
a big screen to play this game because
like I said it is slippery and you know
you can slip off very easily and you
have to be on those chains the exact way
you know I just saw you keep slipping
off there as well or it doesn't even
grab it so I actually was getting really
pissed on playing this game the second
time the first time I played it actually
look at the special features I get
relatively far I think I get to like
stage 15 and another e-patient with
games anymore I you know the things
where like you have to wait for a
character or something to move and then
you go it's like I hate that I just want
to blow shit up sadly I wish you know
there's a time I was more patient with
games or whatever I could play like
Zelda Metroid and you know and go on
adventures and find stuff it's like no
not now I just I want destroy things
horrible to say I don't have much time
game okay I'm busy I just give me shit
to blow up I'm good so and those game
does have a little bit of that I mean
there's not like a lot of mazes or
anything there's one or two where you
have to like figure stuff out and
but and again if you watch the little
extra video on here you'll see rob was
reading the instruction book could to
figure out why the hell were in this
lame world and he actually explained the
story I'm like okay we gotta put this in
the we can't put this in there cuz this
is the dumbest story and my thought is I
think this was a different game I don't
think this originally you like they said
hey make a Blues Brothers game and they
started doing this I think they got this
game from whatever Japan and just had
some sort of weird character that they
didn't like or they didn't think that
good markets are like yeah whatever
we've done yet you know but we don't
want to throw a ton of my well what
could we get the rights to the be pre
chief yeah a Blues Brothers okay on our
joke we were talking about as maybe link
getting hit in the balls um I thought it
sound more like Sam Kinison so I did the
same cancer joke
let's see Malakal coming Ethan cake is
similar to coming I was like it when I
can do the nostalgia critic at a
different location aside from the desk
you don't always have to be hunched over
and stuff like that plus that's a comfy
chair so I like doing that the next time
I do my commercials review I'll probably
do that probably just do it the chair
again I might even wear that I don't
doughnut shirt you know what's the point
is you put all those records there's
just to take him away and there's a lot
now again when I'm having these
reactions I always do a lot of takes for
something because you never know it's
like sometimes the first take will be
fine sometimes it'll be the last take or
even third take so I do a lot you know
like that where I go what the fuck what
the fuck
I mean you play with and see which one
works the best believe it or not it's
not always the high-pitched squeaky one
sometimes you know just a very quiet one
is the funniest and it's tough again
because I don't know I mean I remember
like you know it's okay say shit here
when you fall say damn when you fall
you're gonna say it a few times but
again there's so many variations
I mean you can say you know no a shit or
shit or shit yet there's so many various
ways you can do it so the more tapes you
have the more you can play around and
you can get just that right combination
as I saw him to tend to power uh and add
for this game it was just one picture
it's where you start off and I think
that just turned everybody off to like
who the hell knows about this game like
virtually nobody I mean nobody
recommended that I do this game even
when I put out the content not the
contest but the little thing at the end
the nerd video saying hey you know what
game should I review ok just watching
just watching me falls off fall off
these chains gets me so angry
it's ie anyone knows me knows I don't
get angry that often but I was getting
legitimately pissed off at this game
it's not the one on the video it's not
the lecture feature this was why I had
to play it to get footage for the game
and that's where it got even more
frustrating cuz you know there's a time
limit and I want to demonstrate the
point when I'm trying to talk about
sometimes it either won't do it or it
suddenly will but then I'll run out of
time and it just it's oh I really hate
doing game reviews that's why I don't do
them very often actually watching me
probably really plays is probably very
funny but that's the thing if a cameras
on me I'll be too nice I'll be like you
know oh darn shoot but if nobody's
watching and I constantly keep dying at
something especially when something I
know I can do I get really pissed off so
the few things I get pissed off that my
bow is the same way be he'll denied and
this art came out of nowhere to it every
time cuz I remember when we were playing
this we were just astonished to see a
dog because they keep running the same
enemies over and over and over so we
just are looked at and then at one point
the dog like falls on me or lands on me
and I'm carrying it we're having a good
laugh at that it was only a few seconds
but it's like you can't do that for
those few seconds all of a sudden that
one level the time limit gets like super
super short yeah and even there in you
gotta weigh that well I'm just I'm just
reacting the review
I think that what's once I just on the
spot I made that up I'm just like okay
well I'm going to I know I'm gonna die
here might as well just be still and
what had happened I can make a joke
later and it was the one thing I did
different with this review that didn't
do with babies kids was that I I played
it for I got the footage first and then
I wrote the review I knew what I was
gonna talk about but you know I knew
things might pop up depending on the
footage so babies kids was different I
did the whatchamacallit I I filmed it
and then tried to create the footage and
that's I found out that's the stupid way
to do it because you never know when
you're playing you might not be able to
get the footage or there might be
something else that's better to react to
you know like something that you keep
dying at like the the chains were not as
hard when I yeah they weren't as
difficult when I played it on the big
screen I mean they were difficult but it
wasn't that hard on the small screen it
just kept falling and falling and
falling it's like okay I gotta make a
joke out of this this thing forget about
it that you know possessed Falkor
whatever that is that thing is a shit
fuck I did it and I did get past this
level again if you watch on the our
video I got much farther than this but I
think the way to do it is just go
forward like just do it as fast as you
can like don't even think about just go
really fast you know don't don't try to
be careful just do it very quickly or
else it'll you know again it'll just
throw you off it's like the most
impossible thing to control it's of a
noxious little snake drag whatever the
fuck it is and they know it cuz look
they put like a bajillion 1ups there you
know cuz they know you're going to die a
hundred times here and they just want to
even more frustrated so now that little
sound there that I stole from I stole
from Donald Duck he makes that sound a
few times I'm here there's one where
it's I care about what it was by I think
he's trying to cook something and this
what
something keeps hitting him or he can't
get this dish right at one point he goes
through all this stuff and there's just
this silence no music or anything he
just looks at the dish served what's at
his hands it just goes reaction so it's
it's another duck I steal from and steal
from Daffy and Donald unoriginal hack
what guys I oh I don't know his name but
he did one of the Lost Levels from Super
Mario Brothers or the official Super
Mario Brothers to the one Japan I did
this one impossible level that actually
starts you off on a clip it's a very
long video it's in like 15-20 minutes
maybe even longer and his reactions were
so great I tried to take some of that
guy I love the way just oh ah you know
you have these really great reactions so
I think I took a little bit from that if
anyone's wondering that's a macbeth
poster honestly it was for the lyric
opera I didn't see it but my parents
went and they just had this poster looks
kind of awesome so I just hung it up hey
no one's ever wondering what that is Oh
snowing that day too luckily none begun
on the camera it was just starting to
snow so I did really fast I did it
really quick and that game I throw I
actually again cuz I don't want to hurt
the actual game is ironically crash test
dummies of the Super Nintendo game and
when I got it I threw it I said this is
actually very ironic I never thought
about this I'm just constantly crashing
and destroying this thing as crash test
dummies so yeah go figure
I just got consisteth cheapest that is
true thank you so much for buying the
DVD I love how pissed he gets he must be
just okikuta angry too anyway uh I love
you all